[BLANK_AUDIO]
Almost done, almost done.
That's it,
that's the whole thing and send.
[SOUND] Whoa, pizza.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Large pepperoni and
crazy sticks for Marty McCapp.
>> Micky P.I., that's me.
>> Cool, here you go.
>> Thank goodness you're here.
I'm so hungry, I've been writing
this algorithm for hours.
I solved the flux photon algorithm.
>> Yeah, cool.
Okay.
>> You know this algorithm's
going to change the world, right?
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> And, send.
No, no, no, no, no,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
You can't die, you can't die.
Just turn back on, come on.
Open up messages.
Where is it?
Where's the algorithm?
No, what am I going to do?
Doc, Doc will know.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Hello?
[SOUND] Hello, who's this?
>> Doc, it's me, Marty.
I solved the flux photon algorithm.
I had it written down.
I was going to send it to you and
then my phone died and
I don't know what to do.
>> We have to go back Marty,
back to the past and then both in.
We're sisters.
[MUSIC]